if you think that the crisis at the
southern border is bad
just listen to this aoc and other
far-left democrats are demanding an
end to targeted deportations of criminal
illegal immigrants
that includes suspected gang members
like people in ms-13
these lefty members of congress argue
that america's immigration enforcement
laws
are racist dana can you explain this
well here's the thing i think about
abigail spamberger she is a
congresswoman from virginia democrat
in front one in a swing district and
remember right after the 2020 election
she was on a conference call with all
the other democrats and saying
let me tell you something right now all
this far-left progressivism
is what nearly cost us the house we
barely held on
to our season and kept nancy pelosi as
speaker um
and i think that the more somebody like
aoc and others continue to say things
like this
um that they will pay a price for it in
2022 because people are going to pay
attention they're giving the republicans
huge openings and really a stiff wind
could blow over this democratic majority
it's very slim right now you're going to
have redistricting
but you take an issue like this where
you're talking about safety and
moms are paying attention more than ever
to this election they're upset still
that kids aren't back in school
and they're concerned about the defund
the police movement and this adds to
that
jesse you read about agents near abrams
texas picked up a group of 10 migrants
including one man who'd been arrested in
washington for the rape of a child
later convicted and sentenced to 34
months there were three who were
apprehended
three conf convicted child sex offenders
so are aoc and her elk standing with
child rapists
because that's the way it sounds
well you look at the ice most wanted
list you have severian martinez one of
her sex trafficking
sal chavez vehicular homicide jose
medina gonzalez
aggravated homicide is aoc saying that
these guys should stay in america
is that what she wants because she's
saying that i shouldn't be
arresting and deporting these people
well does she want them in her district
to prey on her constituents
i think someone needs to ask her that
question and not to mention the amount
of fentanyl that's pouring over
more fentanyl is poured over in the
first three months of biden's
administration
than the whole of 2020
that we're stretched so thin it's coming
through the desert it's coming across
ports of entry we just can't keep up of
it and we're talking like pounds of it
when like a microgram can kill you
that's how deadly it is
but i gotta go back and fact check juan
because he cherry-picked the information
and it's actually false texas seven day
average for
deaths the last three weeks these are
updated numbers
went from 50 to 49 to 44.
that is a solid and consistent decrease
in texas deaths juan
well what i just said to you was the
percentages were up but i i
i'm moving on to this topic but i i just
want to say you know i think
aoc is saying that there are
inconsistencies
in terms of how we have to apply
deportation who gets targeted and who
doesn't
i'm not going to go into her argument
but i will say this
and i've been saying this all along i
think on immigration there's just too
much
political posturing and in this case it
would be too much posturing
coming from the left and from the
democrats i mean the the republicans
clearly posture when it comes to this
and we talked about the tweets and the
selfies and
all of that but to my mind we need
comprehensive immigration reform
that would speak to how we go about
deportations
but i mean there's so much we agree on
in terms of doing something about people
who already here
about doing something for the dreamers
about people here who are here on
temporary
status the farm workers i don't
understand why we can't
i mean republicans agreed to a deal back
in 2013 now they're running away from it
and now you get people like aoc
putting a political agenda on top of it
we'll never get a solution
we need a solution stop it politicians
right
well i think that people would take
issue greg with being called a racist if
you believe in immigration laws and a
border
and um also that
kotlin criminals is bad yeah the um
they have they're using a new phrase
called the uh i'm going to try to
pronounce write the
carceral approach right have you heard
that phrase yes that means jailing
uh so you can't jail them and you can't
deport them
so what are you gonna do what's the
non-carceral
approach and by the way when you're
talking about inconsistencies and
deportation
the whole what they're objecting to is
the prioritizing of deport
deporting gang members so i have two
solutions because
juan asks for solutions and the problem
with the democrats is
they don't have any solutions except
these ones that's why everybody's
pissed off so i came up with two if
you're a democrat who feels strongly
about not
deport deporting gang members i have an
adopt
a gang banger charity for just 350 bucks
a month
you can adopt a gang banger okay each
week you're going to get a photo and a
handwritten letter
from the gangbanger telling you who he's
assaulted and raped and murdered and in
three months he can be yours to live at
your house
i also have another idea please don't
call them an animal though because
they're all god's creatures
now another idea i call this the idiot
thug exchange program and it works like
this we will keep one of your thugs
as long as they're under 25 because
there's a possibility of rehabilitation
in return you get two far left media
academics who are over 25
because they aren't rehabbed they're not
ability there's no ability to rehab them
because the ideas are so poisoned in
their brain they come up with really
stupid ideas
i'll take a gang banger over a gender
studies professor
in a heartbeat not maybe as a next-door
neighbor but you know
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else